hello everyone I'm going to talk about
my project that is transcriptomic data
analysis on ovarian
cancer ovarian cancer is the fifth most
lethal cancer in women accounting for
the majority of gynecological cancer
deaths in 2018 there were an estimated 2
lak 95,000 Oban cancer diagnosis and 1
lakh 184,000 deaths
worldwide factors that increase your
risk of ovarian cancers are getting
older being overweight having children
later or never having a full-term
pregnancy taking hormone therapy after
menopause having a family history of
ovarian cancer breast cancer colal
cancer and
smoking ovarian cancer diagnosis
typically involves a combination of
medical history review physical
examination imaging test and Laboratory
test symptoms of ovarian cancer are
fatigue weight loss discomfort in the
pelvic area changes in Bobble habits a
frequent need to urinate abdominal
blotting or
swelling treatment of ovine cancer the
first treatment is speal typos protein
that is spoke which suppresses
proliferations and promotes apoptosis in
human ovarian cancer cells by inhibiting
the H signaling
pathway the second one is combination of
fism ab bism ab and Metron
cyclophosphomide
combination of these three medicines are
for the patient with recurrent Platinum
sensitive Platinum resistant or
refractory epithelial ovarian fallopian
tube or primary peronal
cancer now the aim of our project was
transcriptomic analysis of ovarian
cancer progression and treatment
combination of fism with bism and
metronomic Cy phosphoramide response
identifying the differential expressed
genes and Pathways across the three time
points the study design of the treatment
was based upon the novel treatment
resimen the patients which were not
responding to the standard treatment
were included in this study three drugs
have shown to enhance the immune
response against the cancer cells giving
pism bism and cyclop phosphoamide
together work better in the treating
patients with recurrent ovarian cancer
the novel treatment resimen samples
which are treated with bbx C4 BX and eot
BX were collected samples were taken
from the patients at the three time
points Baseline means bbx after four
cycles of treatment means c4x and at the
end of treatment means eot
VX so here is the methodology olog the
first step was Data extraction the
Second Step was exploratory data
analysis then we did statistical
analysis then pathway analysis and then
network
analysis so the first step was Data
extraction the data was extracted from
Geo database and the title of the data
set was integrative multiomic approach
unveils underlying etiology of response
to npd1 in combination with
anti-angiogenic therapy in precurrent
ovarian
cancer firstly series metric file was
downloaded from the data set which
defines a set of related samples
considered to be a part of a group how
the samples are related and how they are
ordered then we created the pivot chart
here's the table showing the total
number of samples of treatment Baseline
treatment had 28 samples after four
cycles of treatment had 21 samples and
at the end of treatment had eight
samples and the total number of samples
were
57 then we did statistical analysis
performed PCA using unsupervised
analysis PC is a technique used to
decrease the variability between the
groups and finds the outliers present in
the sample to normalize the data
downloaded raw file was run on Excel
inside Excel samples were grouped and
the spreadsheet was transformed to text
file format before uploaded to perform
PCA pipeline the tool used was PCR
Library which is a statistical process
that uses an orthogonal transformation
which converts a set of observations of
possibly correlated variables into a set
of values of linearly uncorrelated
variables called principal
component now here are the results of
PCA and the first diagram is showing
outliers after removing the outliers
from the spreadsheet file PC was
performed again and hence the plot
showing better clustering of
samples then we did differential
expression analysis differential
expression analysis means taking the
normalized read count data and
Performing statistical analysis to
discover quantitative changes in
expression levels between experimental
groups raw data was grouped as per
samples from Baseline and four cycles of
treatment zero errors and duplicate
values were screened and removed from
the spreadsheet spreadsheet was
converted back to text format before
being uploaded to perform differential
expression analysis pipeline same
criteria were used for the group
Baseline and at the end of treatment and
the tool used were dct2 dc2 is a popular
software package us used for the
analysis of differential gene expression
from RNA seek data it provides
statistical methods to identify genes
that are differentially expressed across
different experimental conditions or
groups enrichment analysis these tools
are software or web-based platforms that
facilitate the analysis of gene or
protein sets for enrichment in specific
biological categories or functional
annotations GSC a is a powerful tool for
analyzing gene expression data and
identifying biologically relevant Gene
sets now here are the results of
Baseline versus four cycle of
treatment first one is the volcano plot
which is showing up regulated genes that
is esm1 cyp3 A4 hrg b a a u GT2 B4 cyp4
A1 suring adh6 APO A5 and the down
regulated genes are chrm2 n pp3 gam and
O
xcr1 the second picture is heat map and
here are the results of heat map in
which the table two is showing up
regulated genes in the following samples
and in the table three down regulated
genes are showing in the following samp
now the table four is showing the top 20
differential expressed Gene list the
first 16 genes are upregulated and the
last four genes are down
regulated here's the results of
differential Express Gene pipeline for
Baseline versus end of treatment the
first SRAM is the volcano plot and the
upregulated genes are prdm15 ACR BP and
the down regulated genes are SST cyp3 A4
APO A2 AP cyp3
a11 here's the heat
map and the table six is showing the up
regulated genes in the following sample
and the table seven is showing the down
regulated genes in the following
sample the table 8 is showing the top 20
different IAL expressed Gene
list the first two genes are showing
upper regulation and the rest are
showing down
regulation pathway analysis after
finding the upregulated and down
regulated genes we found how these genes
affect the pathways of the patient two
major tools which were used for the
pathway analysis are and richer and
David and richer is a vet based tool for
Gene over representation anal analysis
using functional annotations David for
annotation visualization and integrated
Discovery provides a comprehensive set
of functional annotation tools for
investigators to understand the
biological meaning behind large list of
genes the enriched results for Baseline
versus four cycles of
treatment retino metabolism resulting in
the highest differential expression
value sorted on the Bas of P value
ranking and primary bile acid
biosynthesis resulting in the low
differential expression value for
Baseline versus endof treatment
cholesterol metabolism with highest
differential expression value sorted on
the basis of P value ranking and
complement and coagulation Cascades WPS
58 resulting in the lowest differential
expression value the clustr for base
line versus four cycle of treatment in
this ugt2 B4 cyp3 A4 are included in the
most Pathways and alob is included in
least Pathways for Baseline versus end
of treatment cyp3 A4 is included in most
Pathways and adh6 kng1 and GCR included
in least
Pathways now the David results for
Baseline versus four cycle of treatment
in this retinol
m in this retinol metabolism drug
metabolism metabolism for xenobiotics by
cytocrome p450 bile secretion metabolic
pathways steroid hormone biosynthesis
glycolysis
gluconeogenesis chemical
carcinogenesis these are showing the
most affected list of Pathways and for
the Baseline versus and of treatment
cholesterol metabolism glycolysis or
gluconeogenesis retinol metabolism drug
metabolism cytochrome p450 PP signaling
pathway metabolism of xenobiotics by
cytochrome p450 are showing the most
affected list of
Pathways now for the Baseline versus
four cycle of
treatment in retinol Pathways ugt2 B4 a
H6 Cy p34 are affected the most and in
drug metabolism cytochrome p450 pathway
the cyp3 A4 Gene is affected the
most in the metabolism of xenobiotics by
cytochrome p450 pathway cyp3a4 is
affected the most and in bile secretion
pathway ugt2 B4 cyp38 A4 are affected
the
most for Baseline versus end of
treatment in cholesterol metabolism APO
A2 APO C3 and AP genes are most affected
genes and in glycolysis or
gluconeogenesis adh4 and alob genes are
the most
affected for the retinol metabolism adh4
and cyp3a4 are the most affected and in
drug metabolism cytochrome p450 the adh4
gene is the most
affected network
analysis Gene Mania it is a flexible
user friendly web interface which helps
in generating hypothesis about Gene
function and analyzing Gene list
in a given query list Gene Mania extends
the list with functionally similar genes
that it identifies using available
genomics and proteomics data expression
to Kines expression to Kines web infers
Upstream regulatory networks from
signature of differentially expressed
gen signature and network
analysis signature analysis includes
some sort of pattern matching of the
contents of the data packets there are
patterns corresponding to non attacks
these non attacks are stored in a
database and a pattern is examined
against the non pattern which defines
signature
analysis here are the gene Mania results
for Baseline versus four cycles of
treatment in which apoa5 is coexpression
cooll localization and share protein
domain interaction with the other
crucial differential expressed genes
variations in the apoa5 gene have been
associated with changes in plasma
triglyceride levels which in turn are
linked to an increased risk of
cardiovascular
disease for the Baseline versus end of
treatment prdm16 is showing the
coexpression network interaction with SC
PR RP nd1 prdm16 is a gene that has been
implicated in various cellular processes
including cell differentiation
development and tumorogenesis
expression to kyes web results for the
Baseline versus four cycle of treatment
differentially expressed transcription
factors are shown on the basis from
highest to lowest P value from top to
bottom of the graph as CBA is the
transcriptional activity with highest
differential expression value for the
Baseline versus end of treatment
differentially expressed transcription
factors are shown on the basis from
highest to lowest P value as hnf4 a is
the transcriptional activity with
highest differential expression
value protein protein interaction
expansion for base Baseline versus four
cycles of treatment and four Baseline
versus end of treatment esr1 is that
protein which when affected would led to
a Cascade of reaction to affect the
other
proteins kyes enrichment analysis for
Baseline versus four cycles of treatment
in this map kineses one show highest
differential expression value for the
Baseline versus end of treatment map
Kinesis 1 show highest differential
expression
value signature network analysis for
Baseline versus four cycles of treatment
in this cyp3a4 hrg s slc2 A2 ugt2 B4 are
highly upregulated genes shown in red
color and chrm2 gam and Oxo 1 are highly
downregulated genes in green color now
for the Baseline versus end of treatment
prdm 16 are highly upregulated genes and
shown in red color and alog SST APO C3
cyp3 A4 APO A2 i t H1 ITI H2 and GC are
the highly downregulated genes and shown
in green
color then we used Veni to create V R
diagram to find the common genes among
the upregulated and down regulated
differentially expressed genes here are
the genes which were common in Baseline
versus four cycles and Baseline versus
end of
treatment cyp3a4 hrg slc2 A2 GC lop and
sering are the most common
genes here expression levels of genes
figure one is showing the gene
expression at Baseline time Point figure
two is showing the gene expression at a
time point of four cycles and figure
three is showing the gene expression at
the time point of and of
treatment here are the genes showing up
regulation in four cycles of treatment
and the gene showing down regulation in
the end of
treatment conclusion the study found
that the differentially expressed genes
that are ap5 cyp3 A4 hrg slc2 A2 GC and
L do were uppr regulated at the Baseline
of treatment compared to the end of
treatment and down regulated at the
Baseline of the treatment compared to
the end of treatment elob Gene are
detected in metabolic pathways pentos
fosfate Pathways and glycolysis
gluconeogenesis among these different
ially expressed genes these Pathways can
be disrupted if the elob genes
differential gene expression becomes
abnormally high or
downregulated the cyp3a4 gene is
implicated in retinol metabolism
cytochrome p450 mediated xenobiotic
metabolism bile secretion drug
metabolism steroid hormone synthesis
metabolic pathways linolic acid
metabolism and Drug metabolism
cytochrome p450 these Pathways can be
disrupted if the cyp3a4 Gene's
differential gene expression becomes
abnormally high or
downregulated thank
you